hi thanks for considering our studio
server pro or shining server pro if
you're someone who uses the free and
open-source our studio ide and possibly
the our package is shiny and our mark
down along with the free and open-source
shiny server or you're an IT colleague
of theirs and you're curious to know why
companies like those listed at the
bottom of our website homepage upgraded
from our free and open-source products
you've come to the right place so let's
get to the heart of it for some people
it's as simple as the desire to help us
pay for our contributions to the open
source our community we appreciate that
for others it's because you're legal
advisors would rather you use a
commercial license than the hpl or it's
because you'd rather get support
directly from us rather than the
community alone but for many more it's
because your IT to the needs visibility
into how the IDE and shiny apps are
being used statistics logs audits health
checks and metrics that can roll up into
standard reporting systems and for the
most people it comes down to features
that help you scale your adoption of our
and our studio products for example both
our studio server pro and shiny server
pro provide security features that help
you fit into your existing identity and
data security practices and performance
features that let you monitor and
control the computer resources used by
developers and applications so there you
have it all good reasons why people just
like you buy our studio server pro and
Chinese Super Pro thank you for
considering them for your organization
we hope you'll take a deeper dive into
our website now